LISTEN.
>> LEADER MCCARTHY LED US IN
PASSING LEGISLATION TO SECURE
OUR BORDERS, KEEP OUR NATION
SAFE AND THE DEVASTATING
PRACTICE OF SANCTUARY CITIES,
AND YES, BUILD THE WALL.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN JOINS US LIVE
FROM CAPITOL HILL.
IT'S GOOD TO YOU HAVE TONIGHT.
YOU KNEW KEVIN MCCARTHY WAS
UNLIKELY TO GET THE VOTES TO
BECOME SPEAKER.
THIS WAS NANCY PELOSI'S DAY.
SHE TOLD NBC THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH A
POWERFUL WOMAN.
WHAT IS YOUR APPROACH TO DEAL
WITH HER?
>> POWERFUL WOMAN NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THE NATURE.
WE HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER.
WE ARE SEEING THOUSANDS TRYING
TO COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE HAVE SEEN ATTACKS ON THE
BORDER GUARDS AND THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER.
THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING WOMEN AND
MEN SECURE AND DOING WHAT IS
RIGHT FOR THE COUNTRY.
THE SPEAKER, I UNDERSTAND SHE
WAS HESITANT TO MOVE IN ORDER
UNTIL SHE'S SECURED THE VOTES ON
THE FLOOR.
SHE'S DONE THAT AND WE HOPE
DEMOCRATS WILL STOP PLAYING
POLITICAL GAMES.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE THAT CASE.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> I HAVE NEVER HAD SO MUCH
SUPPORT AS I HAVE IN THE LAST
WEEK OVER MY STANCE FOR BORDER
SECURITY WITHOUT A STRONG FORM
OF BARRIER.
CALL IT WHAT YOU WILL.
BUT WITHOUT A WALL, YOU CANNOT
HAVE BORDER SECURITY.
WE NEVER HAD MORE PEOPLE WANTING
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE ECONOMY
AND WITH A LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
WE ARE DOING GREAT AS A COUNTRY.
>> IT SEEMED LIKE A FORCEFUL
CASE FROM THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, BUT YOU
HELPED CRAFT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY MESSAGE.
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIALS DID NOT GET THE
PRESIDENT OUT THERE SOONER?
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS YOU HAD
NANCY PELOSI IN HAWAII AND KARL
ROVE SAYING WHY ISN'T THE
PRESIDENT USING THE BULLY
PULPIT?
>> I THINK HAS BEEN USING IT.
ANYBODY CONFUSED IS NOT
LISTENING.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
COULD BE ANY CLEARER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T WANT
TO SEE GAMES WHERE 25% OF OUR
GOVERNMENT IS SHUTDOWN.
THE BILL THE DEMOCRATS ARE
PUTTING ON THE FLOOR ARE
STRIPPING ALL OUT OF THE MONEY
THAT PROMOTE LIFE AND ALLOW
ABORTION.
OF COURSE, WE WON'T SUPPORT
THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SICK OF
IT.
THEY WANT TO SEE THE BORDERS
SECURE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
FIGHT FOR THAT.
I WAS PLEASEED TO SEE LEADER
McCONNELL MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ON A FOOL'S ERRAND
TO MAKE A STATEMENT WHILE WE PUT
THE SECURITY OF THE NATION AT
RISK.
>> YOU SAY DEMOCRACY ARE PLAYING
GAME.
LISTEN TO A SAMPLING OF WHAT
SOME DEMOCRATS SAID IN THE LAST
24 TO 48 HOURS.
>> SHE WILL CUT YOUR HEAD OFF
AND YOU WON'T KNOW YOU ARE
BLEEDING.
>> LIKE HITLER TOOK OVER THE
NAZI PARTY, TRUMP TOOK OVER THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT.
YOU HAVE THE SPEAKER TELLING NBC
YESTERDAY, NO, NO, NO.
THERE WILL BE NO WALL.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT RHETORIC.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I THINK THEY OUGHT TO KEEP
TALKING.
I THINK THE MORE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE HOW RADICAL AND OUT
OF TOUCH THE DEMOCRATS ARE, THE
MORE THEY WILL REGRET THE FACT
THAT THE DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
WE FACE HUGE CHALLENGES IN THIS
COUNTRY FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE THIS ECONOMY THAT IS
BOOMING BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT TAX CUTS IN PLACE AND
WORKING US WITH ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THE HOUSE,
ROLLING BACK THE STRANGLING
REGULATIONS FROM THE OBAMA ERA.
THE MORE THE DEMOCRATS ARE OUT
THERE SOUNDING RADICAL AND
SOCIALISTS, THE BETTER IT IS FOR
THE REPUBLICANS AND THE BETTER
IT IS FOR THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE WILL SEE THE CHOICE THEY
HAVE TO MAKE IN 2020 AND THEY
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH THINGS FOR
THE NATION AND NOT ON THE FAR